alright we talk about some video games
yeah I guess yeah I have this title does
is far harbour worth buying I'm a
massive fallout for fun I love playing
it you enjoy fallout 4 and you gave it a
nine out of 10 nice yeah Rob handlery
you also enjoyed fallout 4 is far
harbour worth picking up Peter first for
$25 I whatever very hard time
recommending it really yeah I mean it
goes deeper than should you buy it or
not because it depends on what you want
out of it alright so what we talking
about in terms of let's get down to the
boring digits what are we talking with
game length we can wing add-on length
DLC length I'd say it's it's fair to
estimate between you know like my bed
sane average like 15 hours if you're
really trying to go out there and like
do a bunch of stuff right if you're only
interested in sort of the main path
story six hours i'd say around there so
depends what you want if you want to
seek out a lot of crazy mods like Rob
mmm you know yeah that's where you gonna
buy a lot of your time all right let's
speak to some of that stuff then let off
the bat so how did you enjoy far harbor
what you think of it what was sort of
most of the activities you were doing
with your time with the game yeah i mean
i was making features so I was kind of
playing in the sense of new weapons well
the new weapons new gear was kind of
investing in a little more of the side
quests and exploration there's a lot of
cool areas to you know every building
has a story which is still the same case
very fallout ish but mainly the weapons
weapons are from the most part fun you
got some cool new ones like a harpoon
gun yeah which was surprising you could
rub if you know if you impaled someone
in the head I made a future where I did
not expect it but sure enough they had
ripped off and impaled into a tree ah
that was a fun surprise you know I guess
some other types of weapons but yeah
having not actually finished the main
storyline this is where I think beard
was they're gonna get at was you know
what do you what do you like how to
fallout do you like exploring and just
soaking in having no real drive to maybe
finish the main storyline but like I've
just explored and you know there's so
many new buildings and such in that case
I'd say go for it
but uh the main storyline I got kind of
burnout on myself Peter he had some
problems with the story as well didn't
really tickle your interest i mean like
fallout if anything Follett's main
campaigns have always been a sort of a
bit of a sore spot even followed for his
main campaign it's kind of fine it's the
side quest stuff is usually a bit better
and so the main sort of thread in this
one the main quest you've got some
issues with it without getting into too
much into spoiler is stuff like sure I
mean lately say that like for fallout 4
is main campaign like the primary
storyline I appreciated that I
appreciated the things that it did and
specifically the the time and space it
gave me to sort of figure out how I fit
into that and how I want to influence it
right um far harder it's it's this very
quick procession of okay here's one
group okay now here's another group and
here's a third group and here's a
problem and what do you think you can do
about it what's your choice huh hey hey
hey and you know it even raises some
philosophical questions about I don't
want to say anything but it raises some
philosophical questions that seem
completely unearned because one there
illogical and to the sort of drama
behind it kind of comes out of nowhere
and I felt like my character like the
character I'm role-playing was
ill-equipped to address something like
that in in an instant and yet here I was
basically able to make a decision yea or
nay that would influence like my
character psyche completely right and I
just didn't feel like far harbour sort
of earned the the weight that it was it
was offering me right in terms of you
know drama and was that because you were
sort of being introduced to all these
characters so quickly and then I'm okay
with being introduced to them fast
that's fine but it's sort of the actions
they take in the way that they impart
their identity and the role that they
play on to you it just felt like it was
this sort of immediate delivery of it
wasn't just who they are but what they
stand for and how do you feel like that
yeah without giving you the time to
really feel it out you know I mean
granted you could go on side quests and
prolong your decision but the fact is is
that these questions are raised it's
very soon after you meet these
characters and it's just kind of like
well I didn't even have a chance to
take a second I mean you can tell them
hold on i'll think about it i'll be back
in a second right but these questions
should come later and and that's
unfortunate but you know to Rob's point
like I do appreciate the world like it's
more more fallouts combat more Falls
exploration is it a big area it's like
funny because I'm all about that
exploration so yes that's interesting I
wouldn't call it huge and a lot of
people I'm seeing right about the gamer
referring to it as it's like massive
thing like for DLC maybe but it's kind
of odd because I've you know that's what
my impression was I mean one of the main
selling points was well-liked Bethesda's
biggest add-on to date right landmass
wise and I found I found it pretty easy
to to get around and you're you're
exploring things pretty quickly but one
of my frustrations as well and this
isn't isin to like the fog nature of the
island right everything has fog hmm and
it kind of gets old at least for me
pretty quick weird like I bought this
new graphics card [ __ ] exactly and
we'll get into how it performs I guess a
little bit later but you know for an
area that I'd like to hit you know
saying I climb the top of the highest
peak mmm uh fog you know like I like to
see some something different i like that
was cool about fallout 4 right like you
get these areas like here's this now i'm
even closer here's you know here's the
blimp of the Brotherhood so the fog is
just kind of ubiquitous it just gets
pretty stale for me at least um and if
you want to get into the performance
yeah talk about some about because
before we actually got I mean we had
preview code which had some some
interesting framerate issues that that
stuff ever get resolved or is guess what
no it didn't ok I'd say I say a little
bit all right ah [ __ ] [ __ ] I know why I
mean I I played the the preview build
river we had yeah and it was unplayable
was like really bad it was Langille
digit frame 10 frames right maybe like
this is only so this was p this is for
ps4 okay uh so this was again this is
strictly in the fog and then when you
got combat combat going on good luck
like it's so atrocious your footage i
was looking at
playable but I would not be comfortable
saying it's like did you play on ps4 pc
ps4 and i watched him play a little bit
on pc which he'll explain also kind of
exhibited some optimization problems
nowhere near as bad i mean i'd say like
I have a I played even on a 670 at home
and then a 970 here in the office and
I've played this game before it should
be us all at 60 have optimized it higher
and it would get downwards to about 30
maybe 45 strictly in the fog and combat
situations in that fog it's weird
because I remember there were some
people who are having ps4 problems at
the orig remember Jeff food giant bomb
was having some problems at the ps4
version of fallout for a proper and like
none of us did at all yeah I remember
the lobby episode we talked about yeah
actually yeah so it was interesting but
it's funny that I get once again I mean
fallout 3 star p had problems on
playstation this will help but yeah it
seems to be sort of a recurring problem
with those guys yeah and it's really
just because of the fog I mean it's the
vault it's either physics-based or
volumetric you know fogging it whatever
it is it's causing that game to have to
crunch more numbers and its style choice
right i mean the fog could be there
doesn't have to be so strong yeah but
we're even like we are you know i mean
i'm a developer but i think it'd be
aesthetically cooler if it came out only
at night right or like you just had
these had these moments cuz i mean i'm a
big fan of that you know like the ideas
of like oh you know you thought you you
thought it was worse now here comes the
fog like in waves you know like just to
kind of keep a nice different pace you
know i don't know that's just kind of
almost constant and it's just kind of
flattening alright we've talked a lot
about the problems are with this thing
i'm assuming it's not a complete train
wreck you know is it fun like I mean the
combat and fallout is pretty great like
I happily spend hundreds of IRAs playing
this game already because it's just fun
to shoot stuff and exploring so I guess
are you enjoying that aspect of our
Harbor yeah dude new environments new
monsters new weapons I mean considering
i like the combat all of that sort of
just gives me more to chew on new things
to see it's great like I like that part
a lot more voice oh yeah oh there are a
couple new monsters that were really
surprising and how awesome they were
like these uh these mutants salamanders
called Gulpers like they are just
[ __ ] worse dude that you see him from
afar and they
come at you and they do this like snake
slide you're like trying to get your
crosshair phix on these dudes yeah and
that's like oh yeah that's what you want
but they're super fun yeah tons of new
creatures and again the weapon i came i
did a piece and then stumbled across
this weapon that someone's in the
comments oh you did you didn't find the
striker right there's a bowling alley on
in the aisle 8 on the island and in it
it's it's a again this is like we're
fallout for me is the best like my
favorite memories are taken away from
where someone you know got the freedom
to make their own story in one
environment you know without anyone else
yeah so it's the story I'm if I spoil it
but it's probably in the end of it I you
get a bowling ball launcher okay and
have at it it's super fun so you're just
firing you know bowling balls that like
dudes head which you had done wit with
the junk junk jack john chat with
because you can put bowling balls and as
well yeah does the character say strike
no even better though even better that I
message gutter ball no you know once you
get the kill it's a the sound effect of
pins knocking down it's like there was
like one guy here that's their speaker
on this thing let's go on yeah alright
so I kind of feel like this would have
been the perfect bit of DLC to play if
you've gotten the like cheap version of
the season pass or something like it
kind of totally not to bring the whole
money into you know whether it's worth
it debate all over again but well
sometimes it is I mean this has been how
many months now since we played fallout
you know Xavier day six months not
counting at Omicron stuff right but yeah
like it's been a long time for some
people so throw another 25 bucks at
something is I think a reasonable thing
to consider yeah alright one of the
review we live on guess one working on
the video of you right now d live
tonight ok cool so it may already be up
at a time you watch this if you're
watching this on demand watching this
live and make sure you to come back to
gamespot com later this evening for that
review thank you so much gentlemen I'm
out of here you are out of here you're
both out of here I'm sick